in the West African country of Benin
where voodoo was born it is an official
religion practiced by more than four
million believers Voodoo's exact origins
are elusive but it is said to have
evolved out of the region's traditions
of ancestor worship and animism Taza
good news is a third-generation voodoo
priest and healed he treats patients and
presides over rituals in a shrine of the
earth spirit aza sees the benefits they
are cured if some people don't have
enough money we improve I do so they
will get money Amanda would walk in the
local language thawne voodoo means
spirit while practitioners believe in
only one true God they communicate with
him through thousands of different
spirits and shrines
even for a priest it can be dangerous to
disobey a spirits wishes
years ago a spirit demanded that Oz's
daughter Hasib ax become a medium a
vessel for the deity but aza wanted his
daughter to get a modern education at
first he disobeyed the spirits commands
but over time
aza realized the spirit was flirting his
plan for his daughter she didn't
understand why the teacher was saying
she couldn't hear when the teachers then
she would never find a good life for his
daughter to achieve her potential aza
has to let her become a medium this
forest harbors the earth spirit sock
bottom
here is whereas IBAs journey begins it
was a grand fathers worshiped on to us
up to you suddenly the spirit claims a
Sivas body overcoming these people
believe the spirit has actually killed a
senior now in the grip of spirits of the
dead the girl's body received gentle
care given with the hope that in time
the earth spirit will return alive a
SIBO will lie here for three days
without food or water
aza hopes to see a Seba reborn but he
knows her fate is up to the spirit three
days later the spirits of the dead still
control a Sivas body her father
aza hopes they are about to give his
daughter back the course of a medium is
tilling soil now we want to
one burger from here in front of the
community a spray of cornmeal rids the
path of evil to signal passage from the
world of the dead to the world of the
Spirit
the body must come feet first into the
village open palms invoked the spirit
inviting it to return in voodoo contact
with the chicken purifies the body
preparing it for birth still a Seba
seems lifeless a priestess calls on the
spirits to release their hold on her
body
finally a muted cry
this display of spirit power overwhelms
worshippers a series of ceremonies
purifies a Simba's physical self with
his daughter revived and reborn
aza feels enormous relief now that my
daughter is resurrected I can relax the
world of the Dead tradition a Seba still
needs years of training but in time she
will take her place as a spirit